- Hey, this is Cliff Avril, and
I'm here on Bleacher Report
playing Start, Bench, Cut.
- [Interviewer:] The Moonwalk,
the Carlton and the Dougie.
- Awww!
All right, we gotta
start with the Moonwalk
cuz that's a classic.
Everybody's still doing it.
You bench the Dougie.
Although I got Fresh Prince on,
we gotta cut the Carlton dance.
- [Interviewer:] Tiger Woods,
Serena Williams and Tom Brady.
- Oh-ooh!
That's hard.
All right, so Serena Williams,
Tom Brady and Tiger Woods.
(mumbles)
You know what?
You start Tom Brady. You bench Serena.
Sorry, Tiger. Sorry, Tiger.
God!
That's a hard one.
- [Interviewer:] Wings,
pizza and seven-layer dip.
- (Laughs) Seven-layer dip.
All right, you gotta have the wings.
So you start the wings.
You bench the pizza, and you cut the dip.
- [Interviewer:] Ranch or blue cheese?
- Ranch all day.
Yeah.
(Laughs)
- [Interviewer:] Katy Perry, Beyoncé and Janet Jackson.
- Oh that's easy.
Start Beyoncé,
you bench Janet Jackson
and cut Katy Perry.
(Laughs)
- [Interviewer:] Telepathy,
super strength and super speed.
- Oh.
You start super speed.
You bench super strength,
and telepathy is outta here.
No, I don't wanna hear,
I don't wanna know what
people are thinking.
Yeah, that can take you
down a different path.
You might hate people thatcha love.
Nah, I'm good.
(Laughs)
I'm good.
Hey, this is Cliff Avril,
and I just got done
playing Start, Bench, Cut.